welcome back to las vegas now there's no
place like noodles well noodles and
company they have officially opened
their first las vegas location and we
are so excited to welcome them to our
city joining us today is ricardo and
seth thank you guys for being here thank
you appreciate it it smells like pasta
which is one of my favorite smells we're
so excited to have you guys out here in
vegas and we're going to start cooking
in a second here but tell us a little
bit about what's on the menu and i'm
eyeing a mac and cheese yeah so we have
our world famous wisconsin mac and
cheese we've also got our three cheese
tortelloni with rose of cream sauce
topped with some feta rigatoni garlic
cream with a shrimp that's topped with
spinach we've got our zucchini pesto
with chicken breast and asian citrus
apple salad and then our japanese pan
noodles with marinated steak oh my gosh
a little bit of something for everyone
and i'm a very picky eater so i like
that you guys have the option to kind of
customize and build it to your liking
how does it work when people come in the
restaurant can they just start from
scratch or do you order one of the
already customized creations of course
you can always start from what we have
and then you can always customize like
you don't like spinach you can take it
out get more zucchini roasted zucchini
or more tomatoes so any sauce or
if you don't like that specific sauce
you can get a different one so it's
super customizable so you can get
creative but hey we got noodles we got
sauce we got cheese what more could you
want right
so we're making something today tell us
about what we have in front of us uh
this is our newest dish that we're
introducing is the linguine okay that's
56 uh net carbs and then 44 more protein
than our uh original well or
traditional traditional noodles oh yeah
that's right this is lean greeny right
all right so tell us how we make it so
we're starting with the pasta okay we're
getting all the good stuff in there
and then let's see
heating up i'm glad you're doing the
cooking i watch from far but it smells
delicious already
all right so that we're starting with
the base which is the linguine but you
obviously have a variety of different
noodles and things to choose from
correct and then uh of course yeah once
we get that going we have it comes with
our roma tomatoes roasted zucchini
and then we're going to top it up with
mixer with some spinach all right well i
hear it sizzling there we go we're
getting there all right throw it in i'm
impatient i like to eat
all right we're throwing the tomatoes in
throw in the zucchini scent
all right they're good
sounding good
cooking up all right and while you
continue to make your dishes here how
does it feel to be out here in las vegas
you guys have locations everywhere but
now we get to have you in our city yeah
we're excited to open our first location
it's going to be the first one in las
vegas um here soon we'll be expanding
and opening two to four more that's
awesome i was looking on your social
media you guys also have dessert right
i'm all about sweet tooth oh yes people
have been going crazy for the pride
crispies that we're doing for june and
we also have rice krispies uh
snickerdoodles that are called snoodle
doodles and our chocolate chunk cookies
noodle doodles i love that okay you guys
have really thought of everything this
is sounding so good okay what was the
sauce that you added in there that was a
lemon parmesan sauce oh my goodness it
smells so delicious
amazing this is what we had for lunch
today oh my gosh
the spinach spinach okay the reason why
we do it though we don't well all this
the bad boys at the end that makes sense
i know you always feel like a pound of
spinach
you know pan and it becomes one bite
exactly right so we mix it all up throw
it in the middle that bad boy in there
all right as you are filling up the bowl
we'll top it off here really quickly
people want to come visit you where you
guys located yeah we're at 2400 rancho
drive suite 100 and that'll be an 89102